Bienvenidos a mi presentación sobre promedios.
Promedio es un concepto que seguramente
ya has escuchado antes,
no forzosamente en un término matemático,
pero tal vez lo has escuchado en términos de
el votante promedio
quiere que el político haga... tal cosa...
O en su dado caso, el estudiante promedio
de una clase quiere salir temprano,
entonces probablemente ya estés
un poco familiarizado con este concepto
y probablemente de una manera intuitiva
ya sepas que un promedio
es simplemente el número
que representa diferentes valores.
Es parecido a un número que representa
todos los diferentes valores,
para entenderlo mejor
hagamos algunos ejemplos.
No sé, digamos que tenemos los números...
ahhh.... y los voy a poner aquí,
me voy a tomar al 1,
me voy a tomar al 3 me voy a tomar al 5
y me voy a tomar también al 20, ok...
Y bueno, que te parece si yo te pregunto por
el promedio de estos 4 números.
Bueno, para sacar el promedio de estos 4 números
hay que sumar cada uno de ellos
y dividirlo entre el número
de números que tenemos.
Por ejemplo, lo voy a apuntar aquí,
esto me quedaría como 1 más 3 más 5 más 20 y bueno, 1 más 3 más 5 más 20 es lo mismo que 4,
4 más 5 es 9,
9 más 20 es 29.
Ok, ahora date cuenta que tenemos 4 números,
1, 2, 3, 4, tengo 4 números,
por lo tanto,
para sacar el promedio
tengo que dividir 29 entre 4 y
¿cuántas veces cabe 4 en 29?
4 cabe en 29, 7 por 4 es 28,
entonces lo voy a poner aquí,
7 por 4 es 28,
a esto le voy a quitar 28 y me sobra 1, ok,
y si ahora quiero poner punto decimal
voy a poner el punto justo aquí y bajo un 0, ok,
y entonces 4 cabe 2 veces en 10,
2 por 4 es 8,
entonces a esto le quito 8 y me sobran 2 y bueno,
no es necesario hacerlo pero vamos a acabarlo,
aquí le pongo un 0,
me falta un 5 por acá,
5 por 4 es 20, entonces a esto le quito 20
y acabo con un residuo de 0.
Por lo tanto, puedo decir que el promedio...
y déjame ponerlo aquí...
el promedio...
promedio, de estos 4 números es 7.25,
el promedio es 7.25
y espero que esto te haga sentido porque 7.25
es un número que está entre estos 2 números
y bueno, podemos ver a este 7.25
como una manera de representar estos 4 números,
sin copiarlos todos.
Ahora, cabe mencionar que existen otras representaciones que vamos a ver después,
como la moda, también
vamos a aprender por ejemplo que la media,
de la cual vamos a hablar después es
prácticamente lo mismo que el promedio.
Pero bueno, el promedio es un número
que puedes usar para representar
a un conjunto de números.
Así que déjame borrar este ejemplo
y vamos a intentar hacer otros ejemplos
que estén cerca de tu corazón.
Vamos a borrar la pantalla...
ok, perfecto.
Ahora imagínate que en las 4 partes de un
examen hice el siguiente puntaje,
imagínate que en la primera saqué 80,
en la segunda saqué 81,
ahora imagínate que en la siguiente saqué 87,
en la que sigue saqué 88,
y bueno, yo lo que quiero saber es,
¿cuál es mi promedio en este examen?
es decir,
¿cuánto voy a sacar en ese examen?
Y para eso, entonces vamos a hacer la suma
de estos 4 números
y dividirlo entre el número de números que tenemos,
que en este caso es 4.
Así que me voy a tomar la suma de,
80 más 81 más, a éste le voy a sumar 87,
más a éste le voy a sumar 88 y entonces dice,
1 más 7 es 7 más 8 es...
no, espera, espera...
1 más 7 es 8 más 8 es 16...
ó, deben de disculparme un poco, es que acabo
de nadar casi 2 horas y estoy un poco cansado.
Pero bueno, 16 y llevamos 1
y después tengo cuatro 8 que es 32 más 1 es 33, ok, 33.
Y yo lo que quiero es el promedio,
por lo tanto hay que dividir 336
entre el número de números que tenemos,
que es 4.
Entonces,
¿4 cabe en 336, cuántas veces?
336...
Bueno, pues en 33 cabe 8 veces,
8 por 4 es 32, entonces aquí le voy a quitar 32
y me va a quedar solamente 1, ok,
bajo este 6 y 4 por 4 es 16,
por lo tanto aquí pongo un 4 y ahora sí,
puedo concluir que el promedio...
que el promedio...
promedio...
es igual a 84.
Saqué 84 en el examen.
En fin, vamos a borrar la pantalla
y vamos a intentar hacer un nuevo...
un nuevo problema.
Ok, vamos a hacer el siguiente problema.
Ok, vamos a hacer esto un poco más difícil.
Imagínate que el promedio
después de hacer 4 exámenes es 84...
y vamos a ponerlo aquí.
El promedio...
el promedio de después...
después de 4 exámenes...
de 4 exámenes, ok, es igual a 84, ok.
Ahora, voy a hacer un quinto examen para que
me den la calificación en la materia,
entonces lo que yo quiero es obtener en esa materia 88, por lo tanto lo voy a poner aquí.
Quiero obtener 88 en la materia...
en la materia...
Ok, para obtener 88 en el siguiente examen,
después de estos 4 exámenes,
¿qué calificación debo de obtener?
Así que le voy a poner a "x"...
a "x" la calificación que debo de obtener...
lo que... lo que tengo...
tengo que obtener...
que obtener, ok.
¿Y cómo resuelvo este problema?
Bueno, date cuenta que si yo quiero sacar
el promedio de estos 4 exámenes más éste,
más lo que voy a sacar en el quinto,
¿cómo lo podré obtener?
Bueno, pues me voy a fijar en el promedio
de estos 4 exámenes que es 84,
es decir, que el promedio de esos 4 exámenes lo puedo representar como 4 que multiplica a su vez a 84, ok,
esto es el promedio de estos 4 exámenes,
no importa cuanto saqué,
al final el promedio es 84  y a esto le voy a sumar
lo que voy a sacar en el quinto examen que es "x",
ok, y todo esto lo voy a dividir entre la
cantidad de exámenes que voy a hacer en total
en es materia que es 5,
ahora, date cuenta que esta parte de aquí,
está representando lo que
ya saqué en los 4 exámenes,
esta parte de aquí está representando que
el promedio después de 4 exámenes es 84,
es como si sumara 84 cuatro veces,
de hecho fue justo lo que vimos en el ejercicio pasado.
Y yo lo que quiero es que este,
este promedio, me dé 88,
me dé 88 para obtener
esta calificación que quiero en la materia.
Ahora lo que necesitamos
es resolver para "x" y bueno,
para resolver para "x"
déjame hacer una pequeña línea aquí ,
que nos divida esto en dos, ok,
vamos a resolver para "x".
Y voy a multiplicar 5 de ambos lados de la
ecuación, por lo tanto me va a quedar 4,
4 por 84, ok, más "x",
esto tiene que ser igual a 88 por 5.
5 por 8 es 40...
5 por 8 es 40, ok, esto es 400...
440, de lujo.
Ok, pero 4 por 84 ya sabemos cuanto es,
es justo lo que hicimos hace rato,
es lo mismo que 320 más 16, es decir,
336, 336 más "x" es igual a 440,
ok, y si queremos despejar para "x"
entonces voy a decir que "x" es lo mismo que 440 menos 336, lo cual es 104, 104.
¡Wow! 104 es lo que tengo que sacar
en el siguiente examen
y si supongo que el profesor me da puntos extras,
lo voy a poder lograr porque si no,
de ninguna otra manera voy a
poder sacar 104 en un examen,
es sacar más del 100% así que espero
que pongan preguntas extra.
Pero bueno,
vamos a repasar lo que vimos.
Yo tenía que el promedio
después de 4 exámenes era 84
y yo quería sacar 88 en la materia
y por lo tanto iban a hacer un quinto examen
y yo lo que quería saber es cuanto tenía que obtener en ese quinto examen para sacar 88 en la materia.
Y por lo tanto, lo que hice fue poner 4 por 84,
que es el promedio de esos 4 exámenes,
sumarle el quinto examen y a esto dividirlo
entre la cantidad de exámenes que tenemos
y hacerlo igual a la calificación que quería.
Y bueno, me salió una calificación
un poco difícil de obtener.
Pero vamos a hacer otra pregunta, así que
para esto déjame borrar otra vez esta pantalla
y vamos a hacer la siguiente pregunta.
Siguiente problema,
ahora imagínate que después de 4 exámenes...
lo voy a apuntar aquí...
Después de 4 exámenes mi promedio es 84,
entonces...
después...
después
de 4 exámenes...
exámenes
tengo de promedio hasta ahorita 84...
84 de promedio, ok, vamos bien hasta aquí.
De hecho es muy parecido al ejercicio pasado,
pero en esta materia van a ser 6 exámenes,
van a ser en total 6 exámenes...
exámenes...
Ahora, imagínate que
yo me pongo a estudiar cómo loco,
pongo todo mi esfuerzo y todas mis ganas
y consigo sacar en los siguientes dos exámenes...
faltan dos exámenes...
consigo sacar la calificación máxima,
la cual vamos a suponer que es 100 puntos,
entonces imagínate que logro sacar
en mis otros dos exámenes 100 puntos,
mi pregunta es,
¿A cuánto voy a aspirar de promedio total en la materia?
¿cuánto voy a sacar de promedio total en la materia?
si en mis siguientes dos exámenes saco 100 puntos esforzándome con todo lo que pueda.
Pues vamos a resolverlo.
Ok, pues primero voy a hablar de estos 4 exámenes
y de igual manera voy a poner 4,
4 por 84, refiriéndome al promedio de estos 4 exámenes y a esto le voy a sumar,
bueno, pues en el quinto examen voy a sacar 100 puntos, porque voy a dar mi mayor esfuerzo
y en el siguiente examen
también voy a sacar 100 puntos
porque voy a poner todo, todo,
todo el empeño y todo mi esfuerzo
y yo lo que quiero hacer
es esto,
dividirlo, todo esto dividirlo entre la cantidad
de exámenes que hay, que son 6, ok,
voy a dividir entre la cantidad de exámenes que
hay que son 6, ¿y cuánto es esto?
Bueno, pues esto es lo mismo que...
esto ya sabemos que es 33...
4 por 4 = 16, 336 más 100 más 100, es decir,
más 200 y a esto lo voy a dividir entre 6,
es decir,
536 lo voy a dividir entre 6.
¿Y cuánto es esto para sacar ese promedio?
Bueno, 536 a esto lo voy a dividir entre 6
y dice...
6 cabe 8 veces, 8 veces en 53
y bueno 6 por 8 es 48 entonces me voy a tomar
53 menos 48...
vamos a bajar un poco la pantalla...
vamos a bajar un poco la pantalla
para seguir esta división...
Y entonces 53 menos 48,
bueno eso es 5
y después aquí voy a bajar este 6 y dice,
56 cuántas veces cabe en 6 y bueno,
la respuesta es 9, 9 por 6 es 54
y entonces 56 menos 54 es lo mismo que 2,
ok, pongo un punto, pongo un 0
y 6 cabe 3 veces en 20,
y sobran 2, ok,
esto ya se ve con un patrón...
89.33333 periódico o dicho de otra manera,
si yo pusiera todo, todo, todo mi empeño
para que en mis siguientes...
déjame subir la pantalla...
para que en mis siguientes dos exámenes
sacara 100 puntos,
entonces lo máximo que puedo aspirar
para sacar en esta materia es 89.333.
En fin, espero que esto haya sido de tu agrado
y aunque tal vez fue un repaso para ti,
ahora ya tienes la idea de,
¿qué es un promedio?
y espero que estos dos últimos problemas,
no solo te hayan enseñado
cómo hacer problemas
de promedios involucrando álgebra,
sino que también te haya ayudado en cómo saber que tan bien te tiene que ir en tus exámenes
para poder sacar 100
en tu clase de matemáticas.
Estoy seguro que ahora estás listo para el
módulo de promedios, así que, diviértete.